she now stars in the Netflix remake of
Norman Lear's classic 1970s sitcom
remember this one day at a time the new
version follows three generations of a
Cuban American family in Los Angeles
makeup makes you beautiful Beauty gives
you power and that is why I never let
anyone see me without it I just realized
my whole life I've never seen you
without makeup
yes you have my baby pictures even in
those you have your ears Pierce
Oh without earrings I look ridiculous
Marita Marino joins us at the table
Beauty gives you power I love that line
so you must be very powerful Rita Moreno
I feel powerful well you know this is
funny I am power
yes I'm power because they you're
described as a feisty diva why do you
suppose they cast you I can't eat it
that's why I said who would have thunk
that they give me apart like this
yeah I'm just nothing but big yeah yeah
circle Norman Lear came up to you and
said what he came up to me at a
fundraising dinner and said I want you
in my my new show and I had no idea what
he's talking about I said okay you
didn't know what it was no and then I
said what is it
and he said one day at a time and the
rest is going to be history because it
is a terrific show and as Norman
involved in every part of it every bit
of it that old fart is naughty idiot
I say he's an old fart I'm 85 episodes
Oh 1313 Netflix and it starts on Friday
yeah i premiere is Friday well it's a
new take on it Rita because you you play
to tell people the cast how it works
well it's about a husbandless really
family young woman they Justina Machado
who yes fabulous actually extremely and
very funny is the mother of two
teenagers I am the mother of the mother
who thinks she is God's gift yeah which
is always fun to play yeah she's very
vain full of herself and very theatrical
very very but Cuba and you know what I'm
saying to do I know what you're saying
but you know it's interesting
I read that you said you were worried
about memorizing your lines I brought
that up well at the time I was 84 when
we shot this series and now 85 I'm 85
and I was searching for words I mean
that does happen but what happened what
I learned from it is that when you
engage your brain it's absolutely true
what they say when you engage your brain
it just keeps getting fatter and richer
and wonderful and by the time we had
done 13 episodes I was memorizing like
this and that encouraged me then to
accept a two-month tour right afterward
doing my night my cabaret act and do it
engaging it's all about engaging and
doing it because I also do talks uh-huh
and I did that for two months and look
at me how alert I am I still don't know
where my keys are nobody nothing I
always say you guys keys are not in
front of it I know right yeah that's
right that's why you don't whatever hell
without it means okay right that's right
it is you were mad at what's important
it's called selective remembering but
people look at Yuri didn't say God look
at the work she's had done she looks so
great oh you mean my face yeah my
daughter said it a kick at it I love it
it makes me laugh because there's no
work yeah I know I but no my daughter
was at a talk that I did recently and
the two women next to her at
intermission said with the most
confidence in the world as people do you
know well you know she's had work Joe I
mean with him buddy it's like somebody
said to her and she said no yeah I don't
yeah a lot of people say that and you
know whatever bet we're gonna do right I
don't hear what do you drive this I'd
look to joonyoung oh geez that's ripping
genes right that my daughter did also
raise how about the life you live yeah
yeah what about my life well I mean you
blew it
I mean I've had many of them were
referring the Marlon Brando episode the
Elvis Presley yeah
well it was better are you serious I
mean Elvis was a sweet darling shy fella
but he was really boring really
Marlon could not be more interesting to
me at the time he was really a nice guy
but he was boring Marlon Weiland Wow
what a brain what an astonishing man he
was he damn near killed me but never
mind it's a good to be able to be here
and tell the story yeah I don't need em
you kill you yes how yes with misery and
ladies and it was a temp you weren't the
only one eight years that write it yes
you were doing like them for 18 the damn
book for that I didn't know that either
I've you had done your homework oh I
wouldn't be telling this story oh now it
look let me ask you this do you think
it's important you tell the stories so
that people will want to know my
corroborate this story don't tell me I
tell them I corroborate them Charles all
right Charles
yes I love you for saying that that's
what my mother used to call me Charles
well I had a doggy name I remind you of
your doggy mind you of your doggy the
doggies name was Charlie Gordon Oh
Charlie Gordon was my husband misery at
today's is Charles's birthday yeah Evan
defy and have any think about that can I
can I do a little bit of the Marilyn
Monroe yeah yes yeah can I go over - yes
come on not here let me move out of the
way I don't have a but i have a cool
evil hahaha no but I'm gonna do it the
way Lydia does it in one day at a time
the accent yes yes yes we come happy
bear
dude you buried a Jew
[Music]
happy birthday Charlie Rose you're too
cooperative watch the hand you know
henna going Wow if he puts his hands
under here stop him okay
happy Purim thank you right we can't
stop that will be recovered Thank You
redox good luck with the show
[Applause]